Beyonce stuck on top Jersey Shore's
Deena has a baby meatball cooking plus
new couple alert the latest on Chris
Pratt and Catherine Schwarzenegger
everybody this is the daily denne denne
and it's Monday so I feel like we should
start the week with the celeb fail how
about that because our queen bee beyonce
well she found herself stuck on her
floating stage set it all went down or I
should say up when a mechanical
malfunction left Beyonce stranded on the
flying stage during her and hubby's
jay-z's on the run to tour stop in
Poland the 36 joked singer was supposed
to drop down to the stage below but when
the platform didn't move she was forced
to climb down the ladder
[Music]
[Applause]
a source tells ET the mishap took place
as Beyonce and jay-z were getting ready
to sing their duet of young forever but
she appeared to be in good spirits and
at one point she even broke into a
little dance with a crowd before exiting
the stage now of course this isn't the
first time an on stage of mishap has
occurred for Queen B there was that one
time her earring ripped off mid
performance during a title concert and
when she was keeping up with sister
Solange after her Coachella wardrobe
malfunction okay but my personal
favorite when B's wig was literally
snatched by her fan
[Music]
Ramin I'll never get over that but she's
a damn professional didn't miss a note
all right guys we're switching gears now
to some baby news the Jersey Shore cast
is adding a baby meatball to the squad
that's right Deena Nicole Cortese is
pregnant with her first child a baby boy
Deena and her hubby Chris Buckner
announced the news on Instagram posting
all sorts of pics including one of the
sonogram
now the Jersey Shore star says she's in
her second trimester and wrote in part
quote we are truly blessed and our
hearts are filled with so much joint
happiness
December can't come soon enough they
even have a name picked out Christopher
John here's the thing Deena has had baby
fever for a while in fact our Katey
crossed was just with her a few weeks
ago but she wasn't ready to announce the
pregnancy just yet being around JWoww
and Nicole did you get baby fever at all
oh yeah I've had baby fever um and we do
plan on trying soon so hopefully it
hopefully soon a little meatball will be
on the way oh my god I love that um
season two has already been greenlit
will you be back and if that happens do
you think that you'll be pregnant and
back I mean I don't know I can't like
tell the future but I mean I hope so
because I'm you some girls it takes a
while to get pregnant so I don't want to
get like you know too crazy about it but
hopefully I mean that would be like my
dream you know I can't wait now I'm not
one to rush things myself but it looks
like things between Chris Pratt and
Katherine Schwarzenegger are heating up
et has some exclusive t on this new
romance and you could call it quote
casual dating that's what our source
says and they add that Chris and
Catherine have been on a few dates but
it's still in the early stages chris
wants to move slow he's in no rush for a
relationship now the first sighting
together was during a picnic on Father's
Day our source says the two were
actually introduced by Catherine's mom
Maria Shriver
and the two hit it off but above all
else chris has told us before he's
focused on his five-year-old son Jack
with X on a ferris and with everything
Chris has going on our source says quote
when he does get some free time he
spends it with Catherine all right what
do we think of these two together like
if you had to rape them from 1 to 10 on
the John and Chris
10 being hashtag relationshipgoals what
do you give them holler in the comments
all right guys I'll be back tomorrow
with a special fourth of July treat free
so make sure you come back here ok I
love you mean it